il ya joe l'audit en exclusivité chez
comme un rempart alors le film qui a
valu un césar à emmanuelle devos
c'est un film qu'on peut pitch est assez
facilement puisque c'est l'histoire
d'une sourdingue d'un des petites
frappes film pour lequel notre ami
samuel le bihan et là c'est impossible à
peach et un pitch il faut pas dire que
c'est le sixième sens ça se raconte pas
alors votre film est très très difficile
à pitch est aussi c'est pour les accros
du jeu vidéo resident evil house you
explain de films tous en fait y'a rien à
expliquer vous allez voir point si tout
et voilà et alors donc beaucoup
d'entraînements beaucoup d'entraînements
karaté kick boxing kings franchement
cette personne est une une personne elle
est d'origine américaine
il vient chez nous autres et esata /
labadie inside me la ssii book
alors les armes à feu aussi
effectivement maintenant vous êtes
attiré par les rôles physiques
oui bien moi j'irai l'ossature pour
ouais c'est vrai parlez nous parlez nous
de votre rôle aussi de femme fatale dans
nos good deal avec samuel jackson
vous êtes une femme fatale dans ce film
m'a dit de bien jackson
là vous êtes une femme vous êtes une
femme fatale dans le film avec samuel
jackson mais quand on vous voit on voit
bien que ce n'est pas un rôle de
composition traduit belinda mais merci
merci merci je le traduis tout bien et
bientôt milla jovovich vous saurez dans
blueberry de jan kounen avec ma voix
c'est quoi alors en hydrologie excusez
moi à temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étonnant il est temps d'assumer cinéma
malheureusement malheureusement je ne
serai pas dans nos rêves ou non non non
non non non mais chez huawei maintenant
c'est à dire quatre mois dont j'avais
tout bon ouais anywhere any way vous
savez faire la suite de resident evil
resident evil tout non bien bon vivre
mieux cage moi j'ai pas eu de cash pour
le premier donc ce serait bien d'être
payé pour le deuxième il avait un album
c'est ensuite j'ai passé le travail
travailler à la musique de nous c'est
bien d'avoir l'argent maintenant pour
pouvoir faire un autre album en revanche
est au contrôle antidopage au tour de
france n'est pas ma mère mon père de
l'enfant avait jeté sur les marchés
cibles a mis là on va parler de votre
vie
[Applaudissements]
milla jovovich vous êtes né en 1975 par
amour à kiev à kiev en ukraine
à l'époque où c'était encore l'urss
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien alors vous êtes la fille d'une
actrice qui s'appelle galina loguinova
mais mam et ailleurs même elle vous a
donné elle vous êtes le seul où elle va
donner ce goût du latin ça veut dire
poulain oui absolument elle vous a donné
ce goût du spectacle votre way en
italien en italien c'est la poule oui et
c'est sa mère donc votre père était
pédiatre d'origine yougoslave et il
s'appelle monsieur jovovich voilà millar
1980 votre famille quitte l'ukraine pour
la californie chaque en fait il m'a
amené au cours de tirs quand j'étais
jeune voilà et c'est pour ça il voulait
toujours un garçon il a pris cinq
c'est presque réussit alors à l'âge de 9
10 ans vous commencez à faire des
petites publicités des spots de pub vous
jouez dans un premier film et votre
carrière c'est incroyable débute à l'âge
de 11 ans mannequin avec richard avedon
c'est pareil à richard dunne c'est un
des meilleurs photographes du monde et
vous devenez super star de la photo très
rapidement à 11 ans vous fait la une du
magazine mademoiselle et ça fait un
scandale énorme parce que quand les
éditeurs république s'aperçoit que dès
que 11 ans ça fait un scandale
oui effectivement en fait et il le jeter
des tomates pourries ou photographes
alors vous gagnez me l'a très rapidement
beaucoup d'argent à l'âge de 11 ans vous
gagnez déjà 3000 $ par jour et
conviendront acheter
après trois à l'âge de 12 ans vous avez
fait la couverture de 10 magazines et à
l'âge de 15 ans vous avez gagné votre
premier million de dollars dire qu'à
l'époque où les gens se demandent ce
qu'ils vont faire dans la vie milla se
demandait avec qui les signent un
contrat voilà heureusement votre
merveille sur vous et l âge de 16 ans
elle vous interdit de partir à new york
tout seul elle a eu raison
oui à l'âge de saison vous marier avec
un dénommé shawn andrews
on est maire fait annuler le mariage
heureusement qu'elle était l'ami là
c'est moi je voulais une carte de crédit
aujourd'hui je sais j'ai dit je peux
être adulte et j'étais un séga et je me
suis marié voilà alors votre maire à ce
moment là vous envoie à londres
pourrait oublier ce shawn andrews pour
travailler et pour travailler dans le
domaine de la musique
j'ai arrêté de travailler comme un
mannequin et je vais jouer dans des
petits cafés à londres et partout en
angleterre alors à l'époque
effectivement c'est votre période un peu
rebelle un peu underground à londres
vous appelez votre mère satan j'ai
toujours très sympa et non non je n'ai
jamais appelé ma mère ça qui me l'a donc
vous vivez à londres vous êtes un petit
peu rebelle ça vous fait de la musique
vous êtes obligé de rentrer en amérique
vous rentrez en amérique de toute
urgence parce que votre père a été
arrêté pour fraude à l'assurance enfin
il céderait effectivement mon père a
passé huit ans de prison voilà oui j'ai
perdu mon père pendant huit ans
chercheur
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu